what's up beautiful babies i feel like
all my intros are like this but i am
just so grateful to be in your ears on
your screen
uh welcome to another episode of get
close podcast and as you can see
one of our favorites has returned for
another episode with us thank you for
coming back anthony lee applause signed
the plus sign went on i am your host geo
and i'm bart and on this show on the
second appearance we pull questions yes
from the fans
so that they can also get close with you
yes this is amazing ready yes so these
are these are the most snosiest people
okay i'm pipe and i'm scared do you want
like a do you want like a cute one a
deep one why don't you just go wherever
you want to go let's rock and welcome
back to my show
guys i'm your host here the [ __ ]
humblest dude ever all right anthony
okay there's gonna be multiple i'm just
kidding it's not multiple choice it's
literally just your life um how did you
meet your fiance
i don't even think i know this story do
you know this i don't know this story
god we don't even know you at all yeah
you guys know well
uh
high-level answer she was on my old uh
dance team called cadc back in college
in uci i uh so she went to uci she yeah
she wants to use you guys graduate at
the same time so i'm actually uh seven
years older than her oh okay yeah so i
was an alumni who would come back and
choreograph and obviously since i stayed
dancing you know most people that like
joined collegiate dance teams
it was like their their club on campus
but like i stayed dancing so i was still
active obviously in my own community
which means that like whenever the teams
would continue to go to like
workshops dance competitions i would be
like hosting i would be judging i would
come back and choreograph for them so
there was constantly like a little bit
of just crossover so i would like always
meet the new team and whatnot yeah
you're the weird senior that hangs
around the weird guy i'm the weird guy
that likes this question like why is
this 25 year old at prom again i like
how 25 is like the weird old guy or a 25
year old senior uh pretty much yeah that
is kind of well not high school problem
but the point is um uh there was one
time when uh
i found out she worked at disneyland she
was a dancer at disneyland so you knew
of her you had already seen her before
what was your first impression when you
saw her were you like oh that was cool
oh it's because you were probably like
in a different head space you're
probably in a relationship or something
so you were in a bouncy bound yeah i was
not deaf i definitely was not ever going
back to cadc my whole team being like
which of the girls are fine i was like
definitely not that some of them pop out
excuse you sir i've read about that but
uh but but uh yeah just uh after like
meeting her finding out something about
like her dancing at disneyland or
whatnot right and uh by that time once i
had gone to disneyland one time i
remember thinking like oh this girl's uh
this girl's kind of cute so i should
figure out you know how to
i don't know how to connect so first i
think and and we have a poster on a wall
what if she has a concept
she was uh she was like dancing in the
parades oh cool yeah she was also a
paradise like a teacup or something
bouncing around she wasn't a teacup but
yes like that like that really really
interesting fun little costumes he's
only gone to disney like less than 10
times you have to excuse some of his
disney questions well that's like a
serious like answer then like kind of
like teacups yeah like really crazy
costumes okay yeah children you know
what i'm saying yeah um
but uh
uh and she we got we have this poster
hanging on our wall now of like you know
those like uh like where the
constellations of the stars were on a
game
we have that for tyka when like you guys
met or something it's when i slid in her
dms
so she has it for when i slid in the dns
that's cute yeah because like you know i
i was trying to be all cool and [ __ ] and
just be like oh man
that was your line well it's because
like we all here's the hard thing when
you're all part of the organization
already it's not like you can just
uh just go on dates all the time inner
crew dating type stuff right yeah it's
actually even more maybe especially for
me as an older person
yeah so like even more you have to be
like super chill so uh so i slid and i
was just kind of like hey i heard you
working disney i'm here right and then
she responded all extra friendly too she
was like well you should have let me
know i would have signed you in
and then i was like that is very
friendly right and i was like oh
i wouldn't hit you up to sign me in
because like we we never hung out but
you know i'm here so she's like i'm not
there blah blah but obviously we had
already slid in the dms now so so we
just kind of kept on communicating but
what what are the things that you were
communicating at was it like liked
pictures like what kept the conversation
so another time i slid in the dm just to
say happy birthday okay i mean that's
fair right people playing the long game
well i guess i guess
people use like eight months worth of
talking well you know on facebook right
it's like your birthday or something i
don't even use facebook but i at least
know that like usually when people uh
wish you a happy birthday it's just in
comments so even like go in the dm and
like send a message that other people
can't see that like it's a little bit
more like you should respond to this and
not just like it yeah you know that's
where i was at if i'm gonna wish
somebody happy birthday and i still do
that even like fellas you know what i
mean like there's comments there's
comments but then there's also like
actually saying and reaching out i
always do that when it's uh someone that
i know personally guy or girl if it's
their birthday i never
comment on the picture i text them
see that makes sense but that can be
perceived as a move
gotcha so yeah so i think energy was
just bruin and then uh this maybe
doesn't lead to the success of it but
there's this funny as hell to talk about
there's definitely one time where um she
had told her homie that was her helmet
calvin who was uh on the team when i was
on the team who worked at disneyland
with her so there was there were bridges
obviously right mm-hmm um she had told
him to invite me to a party okay
okay that's the girl okay so he invites
me to parties
yeah this post
this is posted oh okay okay so so she's
she's making calvin's probably like [ __ ]
man i liked her so much all right he's
gay he's gay oh okay okay damn it i
can't create drama
and uh and so he invites me and i
actually go i had no idea that it was
like through her doing but the funny
part what's funny now because obviously
you know
i love her but is my ex-girlfriend from
the team also shows up at this party
that i haven't seen a while and me and
her super amicable okay like it's
everybody like uh we were both directors
at different times like she bound
chicka-bow wow
point is
no because what if like you know you're
amicable but then you see her and you're
like
she is a beautiful person she's a
wonderful human being okay let's just
keep it at that especially while we keep
it at that bro well who are you more
[Laughter]
surroundings okay no that's the point
yeah yeah yeah when i see her i'm like
that's my it's not called the aw it's
not called the hot that's called the
awkwardness
all right like [ __ ] tongue rolls out
like a red carpet
um and then and then so my ex-girlfriend
shows up i haven't seen a long time we
end up catching up because it's just
like we haven't seen and then we end up
leaving the party together ah that's not
a good look but it was funny as [ __ ]
because like that's like the worst
situation i could have before i had no
idea what's going on
did that frustrate her a little bit she
she thought like that kind of like ended
it for her a little bit she's like oh
they're rekindling it yeah but but
nothing happened we're super just like
we're just friends and you know we just
kept in touch and things ended up
working out it's cool i don't want to
wait
that's what she heard as you guys were
like walking away she's like [ __ ] when
did it cross oh no dawson's creepy [ __ ]
oh that's true when did it cross over
when did it go from like
where we were kind of in this
uh
dance group together but then now we're
friends beyond it and then now we're
uh
yeah so we were never even on the dance
team together you know what i'm saying
or the same crew right yeah we were just
always seeing each other at different
types of events or i would come back and
choreograph right um but you know i
think after like breaking the ice and
messaging and the dms like once
conversations start to just like slowly
pick up i think like the talking started
happening and once like the talking
started happening like for me
maybe it's also easier because um i'm
older that like it's a lot easier for me
to be like all right let's go on a date
like i don't i don't it's i don't have
to like ask you out or like you know
make it official i'm not so like caught
up on like maybe the way that we saw a
relationship building in like high
school and stuff right it's a lot easier
to be like
uh what is this uh what do you want to
do is it cool no brother it's not that
you're older it's just you're just
mature because i know people that are my
age
um that i've had conversations with that
are still like playing a game and i'm
like bro you can't be playing games yeah
if you're trying to find someone real
yeah and that's the funny thing too
because like i like i said like we're
we're kind of like in a crew in that way
so it's like i'm not trying to just hook
up with her yeah that's actually way
actually really we went on a couple of
dates for a couple months before uh i
even felt comfortable going all the way
with dirty that was actually one of
those like like can't can't have sex
early just in case what i'm saying is
she was she like
so in the beginning stages was she a
little bit more down to go all the way
more than you oh yeah damn yeah she
wanted this good filipino yeah but no
philippine right
it was it was just you know like
all i'm saying i don't i won't speak up
after but for myself it was so clearly
like i can't this is not like a hidden
and quitted type thing regardless of
like knowing how i feel um so i had to
take even longer with it but there was
like even on our first day i took her to
like um
laguna beach area because again uh we
were in irvine so like that's right the
closest nicest like type of spot right
yeah so we go to look at his mad q and
just take her out to eat and stuff like
that and we [ __ ] fly a kite we still
have that that same kind
it was just one of those little shops
that has like you know floaties random
stuff for the ocean that's awesome saw a
blue kite i was like you ever flown with
kai she's like no i'm like [ __ ] so we
bought a kite for like 10 bucks and we
still have that cuz you need to teach
taika how to fly kite it's fun dude i
tried i bought a professional one too
don't do the professional ones he
doesn't know how to fly a kite so you
have to teach me we're gonna win if you
get the crazy one that's hard to fly you
get like the [ __ ] just one string and
then you pull up the win win that's it
you need to teach him and then teach me
after all right but uh but i remember
telling her i was like at that point in
my life too with like the not trying to
you know do so not playing games that i
remember being like
hey you're like super nervous right now
huh cause she was just being like kind
of damn
i like how you make her even more
nervous but at the same time like you
know me like you like that's not like
off for me to do i think it breaks the
ice a little more yeah yeah yeah
so what did she say
she was like
[Laughter]
you know honestly she admitted to it and
and i swear all of the things that were
in my head of like you know how you have
like a [ __ ] checklist
uh it's not as she didn't hit my
checklist it was just more like i didn't
it wasn't so clearly like oh this is
like this is her this is the one yeah
not at all for a long time and i don't
mean that as a diss you know because
even my ex-girlfriend before that i was
like this is the one well you were also
so focused um i think at that point you
were like in the thick of like
upward trending with like hinges and
everything well actually uh when i first
started daniel we went on that one day
and then i went to china for my first
time for three weeks
so and so you already know my
relationship with china like once i
started it almost didn't stop it only
continued to rise yeah so going on one
day with her and then going on a
three-week china trip i honestly thought
it was gonna end yeah yeah and and and
we just kept talking and it was
literally for and i'm again i don't mean
this is this but maybe like
four years
out of our seven years of dating maybe
for like four years there will be
moments where i'm like is this enough
but then i'd be like
there's no problem and i'm still having
fun so let's just like roll with the
punches because everything i was like
has to be this way in my life or the
girl's gotta be like this i'm looking
for this type of woman that she didn't
work out and i was like i'm having fun
yeah and everything's just chill and i
maybe that's okay
and then somewhere like years after
dating just whether it's the comfort or
the building your life and understanding
that like we can do this for a long time
and not get like frustrated and then the
pandemic the pandemic was like the
cherry on the on top i heard that for a
lot of relationships make or break yeah
it was very if i was nervous i was like
i have never honestly for seven years
i've never been
with nina for more than three months at
a time
let alone stuck in the house
so even if i was home for three months
which would be the longest
even then that's pockets of of spending
time when you can get the hustle going
get the work done workshop other [ __ ]
with you know what i mean build business
what the [ __ ] this was like uh not only
was everybody was stuck at home but you
also didn't know if you could do
anything so people just kind of chilled
and we just [ __ ]
just stuck through it and i don't know
we just got super close
i had hell of fun i still have hell of
fun and and that's why i propose this
year that's so cute because like i
finally even for myself i finally had a
clarity i'm like i'm like she's the one
and it took a long time i love these
[ __ ] stories dude it's so cute that's
tight it's also tight kind of like going
through this roller coaster of like is
it is it not [ __ ] it i'm gonna do my
thing and then going oh [ __ ] here it is
yeah sick yeah she's like what i didn't
know i wanted but for sure who i need
yeah i love that okay that was a really
good question um
let me see where's another one
okay
i don't even know if you're gonna relate
to this if we don't we'll move past it
did anthony grow up watching any chinese
dramas in his household if so do you
have a favorite show
i don't even vietnamese or korean too
yeah i don't have anything that i can
name because uh i wasn't like that
the only reason why that i was watching
was because my mom would always go to
like like garden grove westminster area
and you know back then they would just
have a [ __ ] those small ass rooms
with all these illegally copied like vhs
yeah yeah yeah yeah and we didn't have a
shop we had to swap me dude so i can't
relate but every week with like grocery
bags full of vhs you know i'm talking
about like a whole vault of like many
seasons of
[ __ ] shitty xerox shitty it's a it's
a vhs tape and like a blank cover yeah
that's rented constantly back and forth
like almost rented like a bootleg
library super boot like yeah super asian
[ __ ] right um but my mom would always
get it in vietnamese even though it was
chinese uh korean was huge and it would
just be dubbed over yeah so my video
isn't that good and also i'll just get
bored of like trying to like sit there
and listen to vietnamese anyway so it
was constantly playing at my house but i
never watched it i never paid attention
to watch it some of the chinese
supermarkets they have these video
stores like in the secret room upstairs
yeah and he was just going like going
with my dad so like my parents were
divorced so whenever i stay with my dad
my dad doesn't know how to like parent
so he's like well we'll just watch
movies so we go upstairs and he rents me
like
12 jet li movies and we just watched
that that stuff i got into like all the
wong fight home one spawn yeah the
china's the iron monkeys like the movies
uh old traditional that for sure was
yeah that's taiko right now i'm getting
introduced to it i'm like [ __ ] i can't
believe once upon a time in china
specifically uh no she watched so we
watched the jackie chan once the drunken
yeah the drunken masters and then we
watched uh
yeah i'm like i'm like look at the
choreo on this the wide shot really and
and going from here to here to here to
here to here it's insane drunken
master's so good really good it's really
good rumble in the bronx roman bronx is
the best we watch this every day just
because tech is like obsessed um we
watch mr nice guy right now every night
on rotation which one is uh once upon a
time in china wang fei hong jet lee is
he with his son uh the music goes
but is the is the is he with the sun or
no i had to finish the melody he can't
go halfway is that with his son or no he
does have a son in uh yes he does have a
son but the spear is that one he's like
actually fathering in it right he's got
an actual little son who's gonna like
learn [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah we've watched
that one many times
like the opening scene is like uh like a
thousand chinese people doing on the
beach uh and they have like the um the
flags to show the different colors yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that one now
you've seen it i've seen it i believe so
oh [ __ ] yeah no these are good and i'm
like [ __ ] i can't believe i haven't seen
this stuff they're really good i'm like
how the [ __ ] do you go from kicking this
dude's ass to flipping him around and
then perfectly timing kicking a trash
can as he's about to hit the floor he
[ __ ] lands in the trash can and now
you hook it to this truck that is like
perfectly time to like bounce like leave
and drive away and i'm like jackie
thinks of this [ __ ] jackie chan is a
goat yeah he's a [ __ ] goat and then i
see him jump from one building to the
next and like
knowing he does all his stunts and then
uh you see the bloopers at the end oh my
god those are good and then you see him
hanging from a [ __ ] window and you
see like the pas and [ __ ] like trying to
like bring his ass back in
nuts and then you also know he actually
broke his bones and stuff yeah he has
that fake shirt he's the most flamboyant
badass i've ever met or i've ever seen
because there's like scenes where like
like his crotch is open right and then
there's like a saw table and he's like
and then they go and something happens
where they like they have to call cut
and they stop it and then he's like
oh where he warms up and it's like his
hips yeah and they're like this guy is
doing like he's
dancing with death all the time and
but he's just like so like
right you know he's like five ten six
feet oh like oh i think you're like in
career-wise no no like an actual big
person
is oh i guess it's for chinese people
and again maybe we always see him with
chris tucker in russia yeah so you think
he's like a smaller five six yeah he's
and but he's
stalking yeah that was one of my
greatest life achievements like meeting
jackie chan
i forgot about that'll be a whole
different story because like i've never
[ __ ] fanboy so hard i [ __ ] said
what did you do [ __ ] what did you do to
fanboy you got to understand this fool
is [ __ ] powerful and the context of
which i met him was through his son and
like we we got on set when he was
filming one of jack jackie just filming
his own movies directing right his movie
he does like we're watching this girl
that he's directing right and then he
tells her to get out to see so he sits
in front of the camera and then he shows
her how it has to be and it's like we're
watching
legend [ __ ] yeah and then afterwards
there's a break he comes out he knows
that the kids say oh i see a video
[ __ ] good choreography we're like
whoa
let's take photo we all take a photo
we're already all dying and then
as he walks back from the break to go
back he looks at his son he says some
[ __ ] in chinese
all right i don't understand it his son
looks back at it he's like oh no they
have to go and then i'm still like
what are you saying yeah what do you say
we could stay we could stay and he's
like he's like oh he just invited you
guys for dinner you have to go to your
flight right now right and then all the
guys look at me like
[ __ ] the fly yeah yeah
look i got them like we changed the
flights we changed the flights we go to
dinner yeah we're [ __ ] at dinner with
jackie chan he's like you're [ __ ]
that dinner you liking crab or he's like
you like crab i'm like yeah i love crab
he's like most expensive crab all china
and he's like [ __ ] showing us all
this fine dining crab [ __ ] he's like you
know alaskan king crab normally us 100
this 200 this big so good right it does
all the [ __ ] we're just [ __ ] cracking
up and then there's one moment this is
the [ __ ] weakest [ __ ] i've ever done
oh no he looks over and he goes like hey
when's the next time you come to china
and i don't know why i just [ __ ]
fanboy star i look at him and all these
people are here and i'm like uh whenever
you want us to
you own us now jackie chan you own us
you let me know luckily people are like
laughing but honestly that's such a weak
ass answer like i don't it's not i
wouldn't see it as we could be like oh
cause he's obviously older than you so
if i was in his position i'd be like oh
look at these cute little kids yeah well
i'll say that's like you know it's cute
but it's like it's one of those things
jackie you wished you had a boss moment
yeah you know what i mean you can't all
boss a boss though
you know yeah he's like
i'm probably a little taller than him
but like not in life he'll wreck you
dude yeah you'll get wrecked okay you
brought up kenja so someone i guess
they're new to this uh to to you so i'm
happy they asked this they said or they
ask what's the idea behind kinjaz how do
you guys think of ninja and dancing put
together
hmm that's a good one
um one of our main mantras is like
movement in the shadows right obviously
from like a just ninja lore cool [ __ ]
asian kids wanting to be badass you know
what i mean you watch all the kung fu
movies and ninja [ __ ] it's just cool
right so i think the ninja stuff is that
and the shadows plays on that theme but
our mantra movement in the shadows
actually plays to the idea of like what
you do out of the light right whether
that be the hustle and the grind that
you put into things that people don't
see or the
humility in which you approach certain
things you know what i'm saying like so
so i think the ninja theme and the lore
was just at the end of the day [ __ ] that
we think is cool as like little boys
growing up asian boys specifically right
yeah asians only have so many cool
things to be and ninjas was like one of
those things but ultimately the theme
and the world you know what i mean is
just like what we like to bring into
dance so with kenja's being literally
kin like a family of ninjas
we like to
be like the illuminati of dance you know
there's just like a darker cooler vibe
to it why not fam just
not fam just yeah samurai was there was
was it listening to the list yeah
was there a list of names that you guys
brainstormed then ken just rose to the
top
yeah the other ones there were some dumb
ones like what yes there was one moment
where we were because we originally
called ourselves ombu black ops right
which i like that which is pretty much
the the
black ops ninja sector which does like
all like the really discreet kind of
like gangster stuff in outer toe right
but then the second we were like oh it's
from my anime that's from
that's what i'm saying yeah so
that's why we're like all right if we're
actually gonna try to do anything with
this we probably shouldn't like [ __ ]
have somebody else's name we should
probably come up with something original
yeah and then one of the things and
we're looking at because again we wanted
to just be this group of dude ninjas
things which we have girls in our crew
now so you know it's different but at
that time we wanted to be this cool
group of ninjas so we're like hey what
about like look up the word uh brothers
in japanese right yeah like all swagged
out
no
he looks it up right and then he's like
oh
right we're like oh no
so
we're like
brothers
right
hey we all do dumb [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay
um this one kind of leads to what you
just said if you didn't dance what other
career path would you be on
career path yeah that's always a hard
one well in the first uh episode he also
talked about how it's being uh it being
a vehicle yeah so like let's say it
wasn't dance and since i know what dance
means to you now
um what would be like another vehicle i
guess
maybe music
music yeah what part of it
um when when i was stuck in quarantine
right i was able to give myself
everybody got to be a kid again for i
[ __ ] played
like playstation games for the first
time forever i was like going into just
being like what am i
curious about and
a little bit of like there's no dance
was apparent in life so it's like what
can you do right
um so i started just like producing
beats and i still suck at it but i
understand something about music and i'm
attracted to in a certain way and even
before i ever picked up dance moves i
picked up a guitar and i taught myself
how to play guitar in all of high school
that was like my thing i sucked it as
well but i enjoyed it enough to always
play it and bring it around and like
discover new things and that's just what
i i enjoy about you know music it just
without the dance there's still music
yeah you know what i mean yeah i will
still love music the same way even
though i'm not necessarily dancing dance
gives me a relationship with it in a
different way but like i'm still i vibe
off of music so much
so and i know that i don't need to be
like the best
producer the best artist or whatever
just like i know in dance i don't need
to be the best dancer or choreographer
to still have a a very very fun time and
career and yeah yeah you know what i'm
saying like i think music would still be
a very very strong part of it and music
same thing would be a sick vehicle right
because yeah
if you're
maybe music will take me to like
coachella like dance did yeah you know
what i mean whether i'm performing
whatever it just takes you to really
cool places and i think i'd enjoy that
what uh what were your first steps into
learning how to produce music did you
buy like a actual drum machine
i had a little one just because i wanted
to play with it but honestly i was just
in like fl studio yeah right and i was
just pulling different bases you know
all the regular [ __ ] like fine what
like different sound packs and like
understanding different loops and like
what things go together and for me i
recognized that i had joy
not in finding the right sound but
rather the story and i recognize that
that's the same thing that i do in
choreography it def
i never really care to in my own
choreography what the moves are but
rather how and why i got there so just
like an essay right like i want to have
an introduction i don't want to go out
the gate swinging unless there's a
reason for it and i want to build up
attention or energy i want people to let
people know that there's a developing
narrative that happens
even if it's just on like the you know a
deeper level you don't see it right away
but you feel it yeah yeah same thing
with music i love the idea of trying to
figure out how to tell a story you know
so like when i started going into it
wasn't just like this is a sick beat so
it was like how did i even get into that
beat like what snares did i use that and
when did they come in or what unique
sound started it so that you got a
feeling and i think that if people
follow me closely and look at the music
that i choreographed to you'll
understand what i'm talking about you
know what i mean it's not just like
like one two three four like i i have i
have really really ethereal songs that i
love getting down to and i think that's
just the way that my soul wants to
express itself like better off alone
because when you're talking about like
you like the story like how it builds
that is a good story i was like oh
that's just yeah like oh that's
progressive trance
[Music]
yeah then it just starts building
oh i asked you guys our fans told us the
other day uh we we asked everybody
online we were just like hey we got to
do some uh we're in rehearsal we're
gonna do some warm-up choreo uh you guys
pick any song any artist whatever yeah
in the next hour most liked we're gonna
dance to it that's so cool and then
[ __ ] our fans chose uh sandstorm nice
oh is that why you guys did that yeah
like it's for our fans and and it was
right now it was funny as [ __ ] it was
just warm up so you know like people
enjoyed it but i remember looking at
mike afterwards and being like
my [ __ ] fans are old
oh yeah or they're just trolls oh
they're yeah they're [ __ ] trolling
yeah then they made the we did it again
they made us do smash mouth
oh i saw that one yeah that one came out
though and i know the next one they're
gonna make is uh we wanted to do it too
because it was second place for the last
one yeah but i know that one
iphone 65 blueness oh jesus
yeah you have an older demographic that
it's it's funny i like i like i mean we
have an older demographic too and i
really do like it i feel like they
believe yourself yeah they grew with us
and they get who we are and i'm like
cool i can't imagine doing like or if we
say something borderline they understand
the context rather than hearing it
almost for the first time in a different
wrong context
um so every time i so he bart's sitting
across me right
pick up on this and i'm about to [ __ ]
you up every time you talk to him bart
likes to talk with his eyebrows and his
eyes okay so now when he talks he'll get
comfortable for the next few you
probably will watch him
um it's funny
it's funny um okay next question
uh are you ready
to be a father and have kids
all i hear again you only have the
people that teach you right because i'm
gonna take no [ __ ] advice from
somebody who doesn't have kids on this
yeah all i hear is that you're never
ready so um there's no way
uh i would ever be able to say i'm ready
however
like for me and just the way that my
regular
chinese ash mine might work like i just
need to have particular
uh even like financial structure or
business structure set in place that
allows me to feel like i can walk away
and like put my my life and my energy
into another human being that's the only
thing that and i guess you will never
have the perfect place for that
but i do feel like with all of the
developments that are going on in my
time of life right now that i'm close to
something that's all i feel like
here's a question that i think uh
might be a better question or a more
enhanced question of what i think
they're trying to ask
the ideal father figure that you want to
be
do you feel like you're close to that
person now
is what i think they're trying to get at
i think i have a lot to learn i honestly
think that uh i'm uh if i were to be mad
honest i think i i
i won't be a good father right away i
think i have to learn work your weather
yeah what do you mean
what makes okay what's your idea i think
he's gonna be a bad father i believe in
him what's your idea let's get on the
same um let's speak the same vocabulary
what's your idea of a good father what
does that look like
i love and respect my father a lot and
the man that i am i wouldn't be without
him and i have all these like really
mature ways of viewing and understanding
that but i don't necessarily say that i
like uh
super enjoyed or appreciated my
childhood or my upbringing and i'm not
saying bad parenting i'm just saying
different time yeah and that's what
taught me like for example um
like hitting your children
like i got beat
and
i don't and i know that like nina would
not want me to like discipline my kids
and
in my head i never also don't want to
she never he didn't get hit at all like
none of her siblings did
maybe her siblings might have because
like most of her siblings grew up in
like the philippines and stuff like that
but like all over there she's actually
the only daughter of her dad because
it's uh
uh her mom remarried
so she's actually the only actual
daughter of both parents
whereas like her uh
half brothers and sisters yeah yeah half
sisters if you will um are only children
of the mother so even like the the
father you know connection in that way
it's like everybody
treated her much more like the baby
because she's also just like the second
dad's you know daughter type thing so
it's like she's way younger than her
other sisters as well so she just had a
different experience i was a year i was
two years younger than my sister and i
was a boy it's just a growing boy
obviously i was getting a [ __ ] ton of
trouble yeah just getting beaten all day
you know what i mean so
um that's part of what i know and i know
it's uh again i don't know if people are
just like if you don't want to do it
just don't do it but i know that there
are times where um maybe inside or like
because sometimes when i get frustrated
even like my cats
i don't beat my cats or anything like
that you should they're evil
because they won't they won't know or
they won't learn but i know that there's
something like i'm like oh [ __ ] oh i got
that from my parents that anger
you know yeah yeah so it's like i feel
like until i get put in that position
like
you know all those stupid things that i
said as a kid like i would never treat
my kid like this i don't know because
the older you get the more you realize
that you are your parents yeah in so
many ways
a lot of things you just learn on the
fly too i think for me and her
for sure we have like the ways that we
or less prefer to parent so we try our
best to be the more preferred way to
parent
and then also when things happen
sometimes things happen that you're just
not even prepared for one thing that i
do think that we're fortunate that
fortunate enough to have that our
parents didn't is actually time to
debrief
you know i think like our parents like
they just some [ __ ] happens handle it
because [ __ ] bills need to get paid
or i got to go to this i gotta attend to
this you know they just don't even have
time to debrief so they don't that's i
think where the beating yeah so they
don't even know if that's huge yeah so
honestly i i hear that and i'm like that
makes so much sense but that also still
rocks my world because i'm like
oh yeah yeah like for us for us we'll
handle something you know and then
regardless good or bad we just talk
because we have the time to talk i'm not
working to the bone until like 11 p.m at
night and then knocking out and waking
up at like 4 a.m and leaving yeah um
we'll talk and see could it have been
handled a different way or what do you
think is the driving factor behind the
behavior rather than just labeling it
mischievous you know so i'm i'm very
thankful that like i have nina who
literally just finished her doctorate
program in
therapy you know what i mean and yeah
and
she also has and she's she wants to
focus on pediatrics so even like her
capstone project everything she's been
training with
her taking on babysitting jobs on the
side her being a preschool teacher for a
year after college like she's awesome
[ __ ] ton of from from straight up just
like babysitting to like developmental
stuff as well and understanding how to
like you know treat so we have this uh
understanding maybe we're joking around
to make it seem light and chill or maybe
it's easier for me to accept but like i
know that
should we be lucky enough to have a
child
in the early years
i gotta follow her lead she's gonna
she's gonna be a [ __ ] amazing person
we also joke around and know that like
should our child
uh when they become you know uh
a teenager an adult it's most likely i'm
gonna have to take over uh would you be
the stricter
yeah also maybe just like uh
we drove she's very book smart i'm not
but i'm i'm also you're street smart
quite street smart in a different way
you know what i mean and i feel like uh
that's when a lot of the book stuff goes
out the door dude like having a kid and
and like i'm fortunate that one i had
pets growing up not to like equate
humans to animals but like when you have
a lot of similarities yeah when you have
a puppy and [ __ ] i don't know about
kittens too much um but yeah when you
have like a puppy and then raising them
they go through teething you house train
like that the you know their
personalities change so having that um
definitely sets you up and then owning a
business
definitely like as the yeah like you
being the owner
definitely helps you because now you're
used to dealing with
a different personality and having to
navigate that right like you have to
problem solve without screaming without
uh beating like you like how you were
raised uh and it forces you to really
like navigate the situation and like try
to problem-solve because that's all
you're really doing as a parent like
you're trying to instill like kind of
like running a business you're trying to
instill your why in the family like
vision
um
and you're also like making sure that
they're not gonna be [ __ ] bags and that
they understand and you understand them
and they understand you and it's it's
literally like [ __ ] business
not to say that no no no no that's
that's good advice really is like that
makes me feel a little bit more calm
going into the idea of it maybe one step
more ready yeah no i think you're gonna
i think you're gonna be a great dad man
the fact that the fact that you're
self-aware
huge um that you're also aware of like
your likes and dislikes from your own
childhood um that's always gonna be at
the forefront of your mind you know how
to explain yourself like you know how to
articulate you know how to like use
logic i think a lot of that like
whatever issues i had with my parents
just never it was just because of the
lack of logic for me where i'm like
wait if a plus
b why doesn't it equal c i don't get it
just the language barrier already for my
my child my yeah my growing up uh
i've i even to this day
like
fantasize if me and my mom spoke exactly
the same language to the exact depth
because we communicate but like to truly
speak to somebody at like you know with
that kind of articulation i wonder what
i would learn about her like that's
that's how far it was so that's why like
when i think about like i know that's
why when i think about children i uh
i know that i don't know so much
which is why i'm like i'm not nervous
but i know for it's not like i can ever
be like yo i'm ready to have a child i'm
like
yeah i think it's time to have a child
i think the question
when you guys ask like are you ready to
have a kid i think the question should
really be like are you ready to never
sleep again that should be the question
because of course no one's gonna be
ready but i think if you can tell people
hey you're never gonna sleep again are
you ready for that [ __ ] then i think
people would be like i'm not ready not
yet no no no no i think i definitely
need a little bit more time i need a
little bit more yeah you're not sleeping
again that's just just not it's just not
going to happen plus for for again just
for the depth of the answer nina also
just graduated so like she's like right
at the place she's taking her test you
know yeah and then she's gonna go get
her job yeah full on on her crush yeah
try to like experience that and like
speaking firsthand i'm like you need go
like you need to figure it out you need
everything that you need i'm here to
just support you just like you supported
me yeah and that even means that if like
kid isn't like in her forethought at all
which i know she is playing for she's
smart woman still too
but like
um whatever she needs you know this is
like a time of her her journey that she
needs to [ __ ] just put her foot on
the gas and go yeah yeah not think like
oh i have to have a kid at this time i
don't want to put that pressure on her
either that's dope um but we have talked
about it so that's that's cool and
exciting yeah no i love that and it's
good that you married someone that's or
gonna marry someone that's younger um
cause like this
i [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
bart [ __ ] up and he married someone
older
i'm curious right now
no i don't feel any sort of negative
pressure from bart ever it's [ __ ]
awesome
all right next question we're gonna get
a little bit deep here because i know
this this time a little deep
deeper okay all right deep in a
different way yeah yeah yeah this was
pretty deep but like in a different okay
communal way
okay
what motivates you
um and how do you hope so i guess this
is all kind of tied together but what
motivates you
um and how do you hope that the asian
community will continue to advance in
society
that's pretty deep
especially for you it's almost like two
questions
like what motivates you okay well then
pick the one you want or maybe answer
both of them yeah we'll move into the
other one
what motivates you first of all we'll go
with that one i don't think i've had uh
as many chances as i i probably would
like to
be able to share things of this nature
but for the sake of
the question the conversation i think i
have a lot a lot a lot of like um
foundational motivation from like my
father
um it's not like he ever gave me
motivational speeches but just like the
man he was in my life and what i wanted
to be and what i wanted to be to him
again this guy started the boy scout
troop that i joined and boyce house was
a huge part of my developmental
everything because it trained me to
one like
the skills that you actually get actual
life [ __ ] and being outdoors and playing
with people and working with people and
hating people but still having to stay
in the patrol and working around group
dynamics even at a young age but also
advancing in rank like
it wasn't just about like oh i need to
learn how to be an eagle scout because
that's the goal it's like my father's
the troop leader and everybody's paying
attention i better kill it i need to be
number one always and since then
right even becoming the first eagle
scout in my troop like that wasn't just
me that was my [ __ ] father like like
that's my dad if he wasn't the troop
leader i don't think i'd be as motivated
but just having that be so huge in my
career or my my childhood like
everything that i ever joined every club
live in junior high school american red
cross
in high school like cadc the dance team
in college like non-profit organizations
after and even kendra's i couldn't just
be a part of it i had to be the top the
leader in every and i always had to be
that you know so i think from a
motivation
standpoint
a part of me might still be tied to
everything that
my father is tied to whether it be my
feeling of like why i need to go there
why i need to prove myself still to him
feeling like i'm always in the shadow in
a good way and also just like knowing
like these fools work their asses off my
dad is not a super rich or successful
dude they had the dry cleaners for over
20 years there was there was a lawsuit
involved that like pushed everything
back like
my family
is not a
really flashy success story by any means
so
myself and my sister are the only
chances that they have as well
you know so just like i think
the theme of like why i'm motivated and
then the why
of like what they also need in their
lives and like for us to take care of
them i think those are
always somehow in my in the back of my
mind whether i address it or not but i i
honestly think they're the most powerful
things that i that i do it for every
single time i even go into business
conversations with my partners about
like let's make that money let's make
that money you know the core the main
reason why we always said we wanted to
get rich was because we wanted to retire
our parents
that's so dope so like i [ __ ] want
millions of dollars right now but i know
for a fact that uh half that i got to
make sure my parents are good because
they're not right now you know like if
they if my dad stops working today if me
and my sister don't help them
there's nothing there's nothing saved up
there is debt you know what i'm saying
um
and they're happy people but you get
what i'm saying yeah there's a strong
why that i need to [ __ ] kill it out
there that's dope now i don't i don't
doubt that you will but for the asians
to add on top of that yeah um
living that
my story is not
uh super unique right like that's the
asian american experience in general you
know i don't want to like over
generalize or stereo you know stereotype
but that is a very very common asian
american experience most people are
first generation most people are coming
here from war time most people do not
have the same opportunities language
barriers held them back in a you know
systemically not racist um
society towards asian americans but like
kept keeping the model minorities
construct like that that was our parents
generation i mean you are moving into a
new country you know yeah like no matter
what like if i go
as i feel like i'm relatively successful
but if i move to france there's a
different system that
is already not in my favor because i
didn't grow up there yeah so and and
that was on our parents to do that and
for us who were born here it is
literally our actual duty to [ __ ]
figure it out and do better and do more
so like there's
no more i'm stereotyping myself i have
to fall into that same time frame for
the asian experience to like you know
i'm just doing what i'm supposed to
whether that's successful or not
everybody in our generation who who got
the opportunity to live in like you know
america with the dream
you it's your responsibility to try and
[ __ ] figure it out and find success
and do it for your family and for your
legacy you know what i'm saying so i
just feel like i'm
part of what all of us in our generation
are supposed to be doing and the next
generation if you have more opportunity
you better work twice as hard that's
that's how that's how we need to carry
the asian experience not just about like
getting our shine relative to other
people it's just doing what we're all
supposed to do here what our parents
like you know sacrifice and all that
stuff and then what we should gain from
it let's give it to our children and
move it on you know that's dope i like
that that is really dope do both of you
guys feel like that you carry like this
asian like ism that you have to like
push the next generation and like
do something with like for the asian
community do you guys both i felt like
that for a long time
i felt like that uh
maybe not in high school so i maybe the
first time i felt that in high school
was um so i got kicked out a bunch of
schools i went to a
boarding school in one of my high
schools
and that boarding school is just a high
school full of delinquents it's kids
that couldn't handle continuation school
got kicked out of school districts and
parents that don't want to deal with
them they send them there so you're
pretty much there the whole time until
there's a break so your parents have to
deal with you
being there
it's like jail right like the worst of
the worst
and asians are generally pretty good so
there's very few of us so i don't know i
felt like there's like a sense that you
need to represent already because you
already feel like people puffing their
chest out all this will some hispanic
games come from a black game from like
white game whatever so there's a little
bit of that i think when i joined the
military that's when i felt that like on
steroids because it was out of a platoon
of 80. there's like less than five
asians dude by the time you graduated
uh because like you know like the 80
people
goes down to like 50 or 60 because
either people quit or people get injured
or whatever then there's there's
probably like two or three asians that
you know so the whole time
especially during the time when there's
a lot of uh asian euphemisms that they
like to share and and lots of like uh
verbal love that they like to give
um
you you felt like
you got to like really
stand up for it you know so like if
someone tried to punk me
i didn't feel like i was rebuttaling as
bart i feel like i was rebuttaling for
not just entire agents not not just me
and this platoon but every other platoon
that comes
that's how i felt and so with that kind
of energy i did chill out a little bit
at ucla of course was like 40 50 asians
um
but
but when we started jk that energy
was there you know like me and joe were
super about it there's no asians in
comedy at the time except for the og
like bobby lee but in the youtube
generation there wasn't really much
there especially
the more like dave chappelle type of
asians the people that were going
against the grain talking about
controversial [ __ ] trying to be a little
bit more hardcore or not play to the
more like in sync or full house type of
comedy but more like like the dave
chappelle type stuff
and then i think
as i got older
i think that collectivist mindset it
starts to
i guess wane a little bit
because
i start to realize there's actually a
lot more
individual responsibility in how things
happen kind of like what you're saying
it's like
every immigrant regardless if you're
asian or not if your parent comes here
for a better life it is your job to
fulfill that right so i start to go oh
wait it's not really like this
them versus me mentality or i got to
represent whatever it's just i gotta do
me
and if i do me
all the other asians do them
then the whole asian community will come
up and if other people outside of asia
that are also immigrants the entire
immigrant community will come up and
that's really how america was built you
know like the first irish the first
italian the first whatever like they all
have like a heyday where they came and
they
definitely felt some sort of resistance
but they did their quote-unquote
immigrant duty and they crushed it and
then that whole community comes up and
so i guess i feel like that's where i'm
at now where i'm super pro asian
american stuff
um because that's those are my roots but
i think more than that i think i'm more
about individual responsibility and i
want to see everyone crush it at
whatever they're doing yeah that's about
you yeah no i i
totally relate to that um but i feel a
little bit more like um
i never
consciously picked up the flag for asian
americans yeah i feel like honestly they
throw it on you though yeah that's what
i'm saying like i feel like because
from an outside perspective it feels
like you do embrace it a lot you want to
hear us mad stupid we never intended for
kindred to be an all asian thing
i get it i get it
i know i know
and we just happen to have a bunch of
asian friends and you know a lot of us
that even like ended up joining the crew
too like most of our uh relationships
were really really built when we were
traveling overseas like so imagine going
to europe and being like the teachers of
like this culture right and you go to
these giant camps like thousands of
students and stuff like that maybe like
20 teachers
and you're like one of two asians in the
[ __ ] whole city so everyone looks at
you and obviously your relatability is
like hey by the way you're from la right
obviously we're in the same scene we're
the only agents here we don't speak the
language everybody else you want to go
eat dinner give me some classes you want
to get some [ __ ] exactly gotta find some
fun which by the way that's me and
vince's thing we have to go find fun in
every country
but you know what i'm saying so it's
kind of like
the things that relate people pull
people together and that's how you get
so close and the next thing you know
momentum builds and suddenly you're
you're holding a flag for the asian race
because you're on tv and you're like
that's the asian crew tell us about your
asian experience tell us about how your
parents came from vietnam like and
that's what everybody else who's not in
your circle sees and wants to know from
you
and then you're like oh
oh [ __ ] i guess we do represent asia
right now more than ever yeah you know
what i'm saying and then so so i think
finding the balance of like
trying to just do your thing but then
also recognizing you know like with
with great power comes great responses
you've never heard that right like the
idea of it um there there's a
responsibility that's thrown on you
which is
on one hand
cool you know what i mean and crazy
because you're just like people respect
you and you have influence and then on
the other hand uh kind of like to what
bart was saying
if you
hold the flag but you can't move the
needle um outside of like just your
voice or what you show
that maybe goes so far
and maybe from like how far in the
industry we've all gone the people we've
worked with the things we've seen the
back side of like the
of american capitalism or whatever
it's kind of like now recognizing
especially at an older age i'm like yo
if i really want to make some other
dance
like i need to get more uh powerful in a
stronger position shaking hands with
more powerful people sitting in the room
sitting at the table
let alone just like speaking on behalf
of it's just can you even have more
power of impact not power to be powerful
and rich but just like can you actually
make impact because you know
anybody can watch a [ __ ] netflix
documentary youtube a couple things and
suddenly be an activist for something
nowadays yeah and stand up for something
but can you make actual change and that
i think that's maybe uh as we all grow
up and mature like that's what you
really want you end up wanting to make
change yeah i ended up realizing even
through the pandemic stuff like that
we're like we're doing stuff for asians
blah blah but realistically
the number one thing especially living
in downtown la that needed the most help
in our community was like the homeless
people so we did a bunch of major
campaigns for like kindergarten noodles
where we donated a [ __ ] ton of noodles
to like the homeless people in our area
while in partnership with this group
called homemade meals to like prepare
food for homeless people in our unhoused
communities right and it's like
we don't blast any of that we don't we
don't get to gloat it it's not something
that like you know other asian
influences rallying it's like we got to
make a stance it's like no we're just
some some people just got to make change
in their community just do it in the
shadows you know what i'm saying yeah
you just gotta do it so so i think that
like i think that that's a
definitely a flag but it's not the only
flag of purpose for us sick i love that
okay i'm gonna close it out
this is too fun
it's funny i'll keep going
okay okay i'm back again for the third
appearance you're really like that yeah
we have a certain segment for the third
opinion especially with this
philanthropic like yeah yeah yeah energy
yeah yeah okay so
uh what are three three things that you
would tell yourself 10 years ago so
we're talking about
2011. dave what the [ __ ] were we doing
yeah i think youtube was just like tick
tick tock right so easy
really
10 things this guy's greedy three things
three things ten years ago
hands down number one thing i know this
is gonna seem like a troll start with
the t t a x
that's the last episode dude but almost
i would have [ __ ] went ham in crypto
ten years ago bro yes
oh my god
i'm not even saying like like uh back to
the future look at the almanac bet on
the sports i'm not talking about that
[ __ ] i'm talking we believe in it now we
just weren't we weren't keen on it back
then you know what i'm saying like we're
we're early
investors and adopters of it today
what's the number like if you would have
uh if you would have put in [ __ ] a
thousand dollars in 2009 when it started
or some [ __ ] yeah you would be like you
would have like 217 million dollars or
some [ __ ] oh my god that's crazy i like
that so next time the genie like i get
that genie question that's what i'm
gonna say yeah i'm like i'm not betting
on the luck of like a horse right i'm
like that like this is [ __ ] if i would
have just
uh been more understanding and it's not
about learning about bitcoin right the
thing that like convinces you to go into
is learning about the world financial
and economic-like structure yeah so like
just being more mature and learning
about how the world actually works
institutional money the people that
[ __ ] do the the handshake deals
behind closed curtains that keep the
rich rich and the poor poor like when
you learn about all that stuff then
that's why you think of the solution of
course it's all the classes that you're
like okay i'm gonna sleep in this class
you're like yeah why the [ __ ] did i
sleep in that class you should say
so that's that's one thing all right
another thing
is social media
i think we always
i'ma speak for myself because you got i
think you guys do a great job no trust
me we suck
we used to
but i was i was maybe so caught up
trying to again
be an artist as well which again uh no
shade it got me where i am and maybe
that's what it would have taken but
again for the sake of answering this
question yeah like
all those times i ego tripped and i was
like oh this social media thing i don't
want to jump on that who gives a [ __ ]
yeah who gives a flying [ __ ] you are one
in billions of people that are gonna
jump on anyway the world is not revolved
around you in that sense yes get
comfortable yes find your lane
but any time that i was kind of like uh
you know maybe i want to jump on this
two years later or or too late later we
jump on it anyway because we had to yeah
and just kind of like
oh if you would have just liked bitcoin
if you would just wrote it earlier
as the platform gets adopted you'd be
like the the head honchos right
everybody would know which is kind of
what we were for youtube yeah i'm not
saying that like you know we were the
best content creators in the game but
there were only a handful
so only
so few people were getting all of these
followers right and then suddenly
everybody slowly became a content
creator and now it's like everybody can
do stuff yeah so it's kind of like
earlier adoption of like major global
trends but how would you know you don't
even know you wouldn't know that that's
the hardest part i had friends like
because everything's so clear now right
because we see how the world operates
now but i've had friends that literally
at the inception of email
they're like
are you kidding me who's gonna do this
email thing right and then like their
name is sam johnson or something they're
like fine i'll do it and like wait sam
johnson's taken what the [ __ ] what about
sound jumps on one two three four you're
like [ __ ] now i gotta do like hello
kitty 55.
69. yeah because all of them are [ __ ]
taken and that's it's crazy that you
would think that
everyone has an email now and it's the
industry standard but there was a point
in time when it needed to be adopted and
there was non-believers so that's a huge
thing i think just i guess to tie both
of those of my three she's like just
understanding that the world will
constantly change and we're in like the
renaissance era for technology and
social connection yeah so like things
will happen overnight right the way that
like youtube happened like that was
dinosaur slow compared to the way that
tick tock happened oh my god so fast and
tick tock now is like
forget about it right yeah it's so huge
so i mean that's not gonna stop so even
now i'm gonna be like the next time some
new [ __ ] comes out don't be so caught up
in the past or the way you do [ __ ] at
least jump in [ __ ] full nude head
first whatever and then discuss whether
or not just keep the clothes on and then
figure out if you don't like her if it's
not for you but like always dive in you
know that still sounds like one for me
okay fine well
okay mom
[Laughter]
um
i would have i would have maybe uh
constructed businesses different
dang
so nothing about whoa nothing about like
your personal self you would want to
change like nothing where you're like
hey man she's gonna [ __ ] break your
heart so make sure to do that or like
anything like that
because right now it's very like
uh i would have done bitcoin i would
have jumped like it's very career
focused all right fine let me give you
personal real personal stuff of course
we're trying to get close bro okay all
right fine get financial
okay okay
uh
this sounds so shallow i love it oh my
god um
obviously
before meeting nina
i should have sled it around way more
yeah that's what he says like honestly i
used to think that too and then again
it's so it's it's such a stupid
conversation anyway that has no [ __ ]
merit so i don't care to be judged on
this um and it's not gonna happen anyway
but at the end of the day if you knew
you were gonna be with one person for
the rest of your life anyway which is
funny because you do know yeah you do
know you do know that's the goal
when you're if you're not there
you're just not there so
and you're younger so it's it's okay you
don't do this okay wait what are you
saying if you're not there you're not
there like you're not there with the one
person you're going to spend the rest of
your life with yet yeah if you're not at
that life destination yet you're here
yeah then go ahead and just have fun i
see or maybe also mentally being like
every single time you like go on a date
you're trying to look for the one
that's how i was maybe that's not where
you are in your life
yeah you were always looking for the one
i was i was not i'm just saying like uh
i was always uh i could have been more
like a [ __ ] i think i could have sledded
way more i was young i was traveling all
the time
by myself dang
you know what i mean
and and like you jacked off in many
countries i jacked off so
much and only a few people can say that
yeah and again i wasn't i wasn't dating
nina i wasn't dating you know my entire
travel career i was traveling a lot even
before i got with her so that's what i'm
mainly talking about yeah the second i
like tried to stay with her and i did i
was [ __ ] jacking off everywhere and
that's it and i think i would change
that yeah i'm just saying beforehand you
would jack off and [ __ ] i would [ __ ]
go way more ham and not feel uh
guilty yeah dirty yeah because you know
what sinful disgusting as a man
the women out there are looking for it
too
it's you know me that's what i said i've
said that too i mean i don't say that
now just because
just the whole idea of like courting and
[ __ ] talk i'm like
but yeah we've had this conversation so
many times where it's like dude we
should have [ __ ] way more like the
experience you bring into the
relationship you have more connected sex
yeah just anything too i mean like
[ __ ] drugs orgies the whole nine you
can still do the drugs probably not i
mean i guess you can still do the orgies
you just have to yeah we'll see well you
know maybe later in life more like
senior citizens and like everybody i
hope not
but you know how that [ __ ] is right
nursing homes everybody's got like aids
and stuff like that so actually i'll do
drugs yeah
right like you're going out anyway
there's a like you trust me
yeah you gotta experience [ __ ] and like
that's the funny thing it's like i even
like look at my parents right and it's
like now that they've worked all their
ass off now me and my sister could take
care of themselves now they can start
taking vacations right but like they
can't [ __ ] hike two miles without
nearly killing themselves so it's kind
of like
do what you want to experience and what
you can when you can when it's prime for
you yeah because all that other stuff
maybe that's when it's supposed to
happen when you can't be doing that
because there's all this like like the
reason why i didn't there's like these
random invisible
ideal arbitrary ideals and morals that i
had in place for no reason and then when
you think in retrospect because i was
one of those i was dating for marriage
every single one and as soon as i found
something that i felt like was a giant
flaw in the relationship i'm like
i don't see it going anywhere
but then now that i think back the other
way i'm like
would you
would you trust like a 18 or 19 year old
to write a life plan a permanent life
plan for someone to follow anyways so
i'm like then why would i bestow that
responsibility on my 18 or 19 year old
self to find the one you know yeah if we
were even in the same uh reflection of
this conversation if i was like looking
i'm like my son who is like 18 19 20 or
whatever and they're like yeah this is
my plans but i would respect it i'm like
obviously it doesn't matter
that's probably why all the dads
probably tell their sons like jab get
them well that's what i'm saying i would
respect that i'm not going to be like go
be a piece of trash or like go treat
anybody wrong but i'll just be like just
make sure that you're young you're still
finding yourself okay you said son but
what about daughter
i would say the same uh
you hesitated i would say the same words
right i'd be like hey i would respect it
but hey you know you're still young
you're still like finding yourself so i
just give you respect
you would say like go [ __ ] go [ __ ] a lot
i would not say those words go have a
lot of sex here's some comments say
those words to my daughter would you say
you go slept more
no open up those legs any chance you get
not to my daughter
what would you say then
throw that [ __ ] back you know i'll just
talk to your mom
really no
don't be that guy
i literally it would
you're young you know like take more
advantage of like what life has to offer
because those experiences are going to
teach you more and the more you learn
the smarter you're going to be later so
don't worry about being a genius right
now be it's okay to be young and dumb
because you don't want to be old and
dumb
yeah but if you are for sure young it's
okay to be a little dumb
that's true on the life experience yeah
yeah yeah on the live experience got it
and sometimes it takes dumb mistakes to
become smart yeah you know or to get
smarter i
i stay dumb yeah very true you can only
say that as a [ __ ] really really
brilliant smart and powerful person but
yes yes thank you for coming on to my
podcast today
what are you talking about okay your
final one all right
oh my final well
cause you counted the first two as one
yeah you guys called me mom [ __ ] because
it was the same thing it just felt like
you just need to be a bigger risk taker
even though well one one's more
financial right yeah bigger
risks and then the other one was [ __ ]
around more that was a good one though
the sledding around one is a good one i
feel like a lot of people
think that and feel it but don't ever
want to say it out loud but i'm like
what's wrong with it i mean i get what's
wrong with it at that time i get what's
wrong with it
um
2011
yeah were you shabu-shabu boy at that
time i was at that time damn i want some
shabbos damn there's so many things like
are tied to like business honda
according to money and stuff like that
yeah but for the sake of not just being
like taxes this blah blah blah
know about you as a man are you proud of
the man that you are right now i'm very
proud of the person i am right now sick
so there's nothing you would tell
yourself 10 years ago in family do you
think that you're the same person from
2011
was that photo no no really was he a
little [ __ ] yeah he was just um he was
he was more uh outwardly driven
what's outwardly driven me like um
material you know when you know when you
know less uh your naivety gives you
confidence
i see right it's like it's like our
dreams were so big when we were 20. yeah
yeah yeah where the world was your
oyster where you're glazed either from
graduating college and you feel like you
have all the time in the world yeah or
you're just you're young so you actually
have drive yeah you know what i'm saying
um and then the more
uh you know wisdom you get wisdom coming
from the pain of experience which ends
up sometimes making people a little bit
more senile and like slower and reserved
a little bit more pessimistic yeah
yeah those kinds of things without being
pessimistic about it like the
naturalness of maturity yeah yeah yeah
yeah you have to go through the [ __ ]
things yeah i was i was like a cocky but
like a naive boy back then you know but
regardless of that like uh i'm i'm proud
because of the things i had to go
through to become where i am but if i
were to like change some stuff i don't
think i had to drink as much and and
pretend like i was like
uh
i learned a lot later than i needed to
like it's not cool to be cool it's cool
to be rich
you know what i'm saying but i think i
was especially as a dancer and artist i
was spending a lot of time trying to
figure out how to be cool you know what
i'm saying i'm not saying don't be like
[ __ ] it cool is [ __ ] cool too you
know um and it's fun
but
when you spend so much time doing that
like the little things in your entirety
of your life like chip away and a lot of
momentum has changed so i could i could
talk about like oh what about bitcoin or
if i wasn't trying to be so cool maybe i
wouldn't have bought all these cool
apple devices and all these toys and
swag out with all this clothes when i
didn't have the money it's like why did
i buy all this like sick ass clothes and
shoes when i'm still living in this
shitty ass apartment like the the
measure of your choices
you know come from like the measure of
your character and your experience
almost trying to like impress imaginary
people yeah like today all of us we can
we can choose to show up to work every
day in like basketball shorts and like a
t-shirt and not actually give a [ __ ]
knowing the confidence of other things
yeah knowing we'll hold ourselves in
that room but maybe it's because i
didn't have that confidence back then
that i tried to over compensate and
actually show it in other ways and i
think that's so natural for people but
again the concept of the question is to
go back and look at our younger cells
and like what would we change yeah for
sure not cool to be cool cool to be rich
yeah well i mean you're also growing up
man like 10 years ago like what do you
have though like you're not in a space
where you can afford a house i mean now
it's probably different because because
of the internet and tick tock and app
development and just where technology is
that there are so many like young
[ __ ] rich people but in our era we
didn't have that quite yet so i get
where you're coming from like what are
you gonna stunt on you're in college
or you're trying to like make money you
know yeah there's nothing dancers are
[ __ ] idiots
i just think it's just adolescence yeah
you know what i mean like what are you
going to stunt on you can't afford a
house maybe the next big stunt is
probably a nice car
like what are you really gonna where's
the flex like no one gives a [ __ ] if you
have a 4.5 gpa that doesn't look sexy
you know what i mean yeah like that's
not gonna get you [ __ ] or like dudes
like no one gives a [ __ ] about that
until you like invent the next crazy app
that came from the 4.5 yeah but then
you're all socially awkward and [ __ ] and
like i don't know that's not true i hear
you i hear you i'm all trying to make
myself feel better now
but yeah point is proud of the people
we're today yes
we could change some stuff it's just to
accelerate to the people where today
faster so we have more time or more
options you know yeah that's all it is
dude i'm so [ __ ] happy though that
you're like i'm proud to be the man i am
today that's sick because it'd be a
different conversation if you were like
[ __ ] no not really so you're on the
right path man thank you
i think that's uh i think that's it
i think those are i mean there was a ton
of questions there really was a ton of
questions but we ran out of time dude
this is a good conversation it's really
comfortable in here i love that it's
cold yeah well we kept the ac really
really cold because this guy's hot and
he wants to look at how good he looks
thank you he looks so good i wish he
could wear clothes
[Laughter]
all the time that's so funny well
anthony thank you so much for being here
honestly i always forget that the
cameras are even rolling like it's just
such a cool conversation you're just a
good good vibes and good energy that i'm
always like oh [ __ ] yeah you got to pay
attention to the time because we're
actually working right now so always
always always thank you so much just for
[ __ ] with us dude we love you always
always till the end of time oh yeah
and we love you guys too thank you guys
so much for tuning in um yeah let us
know in the comments who else we should
bring on and uh if you have any more
questions send them our way thank you so
much and see you guys next time